this is a Fox News Alert Joe Biden
finally responding to mounting
allegations of inappropriately touching
women for are now speaking out about the
former VP's behavior with two more
coming forward last night
Biden addressing the allegations earlier
I've always tried to make a human
connection that's my responsibility I
think I shake hands I hug people I I
grab men and little by the shoulders and
say you can do this and whether they're
women it's the way I've always been it's
the way I've tried to show I care about
them and I'm listening you know social
norms have began to change they've
shifted and the boundaries of protecting
personal space have been reset and I get
it but we'll be more mindful respectful
of people's personal space the idea that
I can adjust to the fact that personal
space is important more important than
it's ever been is it is it's just
unthinkable
I will alright let's go to the Democrat
at the table here mister Williams
not the smoothest roll out for mr. Biden
you've had the indecision the apology
tour and now the women how do you think
he's doing so far well I think he should
do an interview I think the paper
statement and now the video just strike
me as insufficient and not up to the
moment and I think Dana's made the point
that he doesn't have a campaign so he
doesn't have a campaign apparatus a
communications shop a spokesman who
could be helping him here I know that he
does have staff I mean there's no
question about that
but for me I would like to just say see
Joe Biden come out and speak to it and
not engage in what looks like hiding
behind the camera because he's just
doing a video and throwing the video out
there you know to me the the difficulty
for Joe Biden is that it opens the door
to the Anita Hill question how we handle
a Nita Hill it opens the door to
conversations about criminal justice
reform that makes him out to be a guy
who's just out of touch with the times
and I think that's coming from the left
wing of the Democratic Party but I don't
think it's disqualifying which is what
Nancy Pelosi the speaker's
it's not disqualifying but at this point
you know you just feel for Joe
I don't think President Trump's comments
and when she said welcome to the you
know how do you like your life now Joe
because I think Trump wants to in some
Republicans unfortunately joining him in
this make this out like this is what
happened to President Trump
President Trump grabbing women is a salt
what Joe Biden did is just at best
inappropriate had nothing to do with sex
well we have that sound from the
president so let's listen and then
Kennedy can react very good the only non
sort of heavy socialist he's being taken
care of pretty well by the Socialists
they got to our former vice president
he's I was gonna call him I don't know
him well I was gonna say welcome to the
world
Joe you having a good time Joe I think
he's saying it's pretty rough out there
yes and especially now in this political
landscape very different than when Joe
Biden might have run for president and I
don't know 1988 it's it's interesting
because it is so dirty but this is also
a known quantity and the president is
absolutely right it's just interesting
that some of Joe's foes are playing the
touching card this early you know
obviously trying to keep him out so he
can't land those big-money donors early
on because he is at the the head of the
pack right now he is the biggest threat
not only to the other people on the race
but to the progressive people in the
race and what they stand for
and what they are willing to do to
dismantle the establishment end of the
Democrat Party all right so Dan Awad did
not think the video was sufficient what
did you think about the video statement
well the fact that it's Wednesday and
we've been doing this story as our lead
story since Monday
will tell you that they've probably not
handled it well in terms of getting over
it but there's been other no other like
big news that has come out the big news
that people that support Joe Biden are
waiting for or even people waiting to
run against him is that his big
announcement so I think the the video
thing today maybe that helps put it to
bed a little bit but see I also
absolutely think this is calculated and
coordinated because what's the headline
this morning two more women came out
and then tomorrow two more mate this is
what they this is what they did to
President Trump and I can see why he was
like well you know how you like it now
but this is the other thing what is the
way we talk about when people we say
people like President Trump why it's
authentic okay Joe Biden is now
basically being told you cannot be your
authentic self and run as Joe Biden and
they're trying to turn him into a
straight arm or what does a stiff arm
robot and the term that guy of a cold
yeah that's just not who he is and his
polling has held up pretty well even if
though he doesn't have a campaign across
the board he's always a number one
Democrat that people Democrats being
asked like who do you want to run and
who do you think could beat President
Trump it's always Joe Biden maybe
there's other reasons for that name ID
or etc but he hasn't taken that many
whacks will see what this what else this
has done but it seems to me that the
Democrats are just desperate to get him
out yeah and he I wouldn't count him out
I think that he can overcome it I think
so too
and for some perspective he's met
probably a million people in the rest 10
years four women said they felt
uncomfortable this was not sexual
assault just nuzzle gate that's okay
permission to do a corny joke what are
these women wait so long to come out why
maybe they were biding their time anyway
good I you know this story you shouldn't
be a to idea prison I always say that
you can state that he shouldn't be doing
this sort of thing but the Democrats
shouldn't be trying to destroy him
either simply because he's in the way
they're willing to destroy it kind of a
lasting memory of who this person is
because they just don't want this old
white guy around anymore and they're
willing to push him aside when he was
out and what if this was all known
didn't bat-mite or now now it matters
now so for me he shouldn't be doing it
but it would be nice for this attack not
to work because to your point it's
definitely being run by a pro this drip
drip drip who's next
it's got that you didn't Media Matters
feel to it where it's it might be a
conjoined orchestration between
between like that Sanders group and
Media Matters because it's such a
calculated take out and it's a point
where like both parties could unite and
say do you think maybe it's time to stop
this crap that we are just we're just
basically ruining people's lives over
politics meanwhile you look over it in
Virginia you still have you know we
still didn't know who was in blackface
the governor is still there there's some
sexual assault claims there that are
pretty disturbing that where the
Democratic priorities on that so it's
definitely politically calculated
motivated and maybe be nice you know
it's not you said older white male and
the Democrats don't want you know the
suspicion to your Sanders is just raised
a record amount of money thicket Caban
and you know to Dana's point Dana you
know the Democrat it's not all Democrats
who are opposed to Joe Biden as you
point out he's I think close to thirty
percent in terms of people so it's not
Democrats we're talking about
potentially either his opponents who are
trying to you know preempt his
announcement or secondly that you have
people who say you know what there is a
real issue with how men treat women and
guess what I'm sensitive to it and it's
not saying just how those two things can
be true at a time and that's what may we
know that's false that's if this is
happening now
this police it is happening now it's
happening now because people are using
it for their political advantage but
it's also to your point people have
known about this for a long yeah these
names these pictures these montages have
existed forever and you know and Joe
Biden's defense what if your greatest
political strength on the turn of a diet
became your ultimate weakness yeah what
would you do how do you adapt to that
kind of political climate if the thing
that you've always been known for the
thing that you've always been best at is
now something that defines was right
that's why I'm saying that they're
trying to basically dehumanize him yeah
and they're gonna be showing videotape
of button at these diners and these
rallies and how's he gonna handle it is
he gonna hug handle it right you know
what I think you should just be your
best self and just I mean you don't want
me to be my best self
have I ever seen that yet no wait for
that